yeah i think we're done with the mask
[ __ ] thank god i mean you're in l.a but
so it's a little bit different but it's
the king of that [ __ ] yeah it's like
where they're like
all about it yeah it's like they live
and die for that [ __ ] or in your gym is
it oh no
my gym we
from the very beginning we stayed open
when we weren't supposed to which by the
way
what they dismissed the case
yes
dismiss the case there you go but it's a
little frustrating because it's like
imagine all the other people gym owners
or business owners that close down their
business because like they had to yeah
and i was like [ __ ] you i'm not closing
yep and then i get to the line they're
like yo let's forget about it
wow so it's like what about all those
[ __ ] money man what about the
livelihoods of all those other people
because i don't think that they have i
could stand up and say [ __ ] you i'm not
doing that because i've read from other
places exactly yeah yeah they couldn't
take the risk and then i think they
didn't actually have legal recourse to
shut down businesses there was literally
no actual science the whole time i'm
like you this is the craziest thing yeah
one of the first attorneys i got with i
swear to god
oh i appreciate it man
one of the first attorneys i got with
was trump was like like trump trying to
scare his mind
trying to scare me bro it was like
trying to be like you got to
submit you got to close your business
they're going to shut you down they're
going to take your business and throw
you in jail i was like do it
throw me in [ __ ] jail you told me the
gym can't be open throw me in jail
because to me it was greater than that
remember i told you earlier about my
father yeah yeah yeah the whole thing
was like i couldn't take that away from
a 16 year old 17 year old kid that i
knew i was yeah just because i'm like
the easier route would have been for me
to be like let me close this down i
could save lawyer fees i could say fines
yeah and i said [ __ ] it i spent tons of
money in [ __ ] lawyer fees to get to
the end for them to be like you're right
we actually didn't have anything sorry
wow wow which is crazy bro you got to
think how [ __ ] crazy that is but that
is interesting like that's just an
interesting way to look at it for you
that for you it wasn't about like i'm
fighting the government mandates it's
like i'm looking out for that kid who
might be going through what i went
through at that age and it's not only
kids it's like people don't realize the
mental health [ __ ] yeah yeah like well
this is the [ __ ] up thing about the
whole thing i don't like talking about
this much because it gets me really
[ __ ] fired up bro yeah i'm gonna do
it right now because i'm terrible too it
pisses me off i swear to god because
like during that time they're just like
nothing else matters this is the only
thing that matters yeah so [ __ ]
killing themselves
doesn't matter suicide doesn't matter
[ __ ] that those rates are going crazy
don't look at that yeah don't look at
that there's only one way you're not
crazy yeah it's like it's only cold it's
killing people now suicide ain't killing
people even though it's just going
skyrocketing and then you think about
like all the other [ __ ] like someone
paying medical bills like to to like to
to feed their family and they're paying
these bills like who knows some kim
might have cancer in this guy's family
and they're like close on your [ __ ]
business yeah can't pay for that yeah
and it's like so that way that's so
we're just saying that's not important
we're saying this is essential and
that's not essential it's like yo
someone's [ __ ] livelihood is
essential it's almost like um
they knew that they were
their re-election was based on reducing
covet deaths
and only those deaths bro it's [ __ ]
insane do you know what i'm saying like
like if if they reduce mental health
deaths they don't get
but they kept them covered deaths down
because they made the whole hurrah oh
this is oh we're going to fight this
[ __ ] and look at this [ __ ] now it's like
that was crazy like i was fighting this
whole thing and i'm like looking at it
costco right down the street from my gym
fully open wow the place where they sell
the food fully open but the mom and
pop's restaurant look exactly like the
place where they sell the food yeah
can't be [ __ ] open dude get the [ __ ]
out of here you can't say these are the
same yeah like if you can't see the
problem with that like [ __ ] how you
believe about the mask or this and have
the cover [ __ ] it's all [ __ ]
at that point no it's not it's literally
like you can look at it for exactly what
it is and be like that's just not
[ __ ] right that's why i get the
parents that are upset about their kids
wearing the masks like it's like
you're going out to dinner those same
kids are gonna sit down the cafeteria
and not wear the mask right why can't
they just the same kids in the cafeteria
room don't wear them well the same
parents are in the club and it's all
good and their masks are off yeah what
the [ __ ] it's like it's the whole
thing's [ __ ] yeah there's no rhyme or
reason to this [ __ ] yeah you'll hear it
there here there okay there go [ __ ]
yourself listen to what we said though
and i get it in the beginning like
creating these rules because we don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on two years
later yeah and then and that seems like
all of a sudden they're like exercising
shit's important you guys should go to
the gym yeah
so did your business do better because
of that were people like super grateful
so yeah during covid of course like so
we had to keep we we had to put like
gasoline and generators turn our lights
because
bro listen to this let me tell you this
for let me tell you this story okay yeah
imagine the [ __ ] city they go yo you
got to turn your lights off because
you're operating we're like all right
they can look at your electric bill
no no no no this is better this is good
they knew they knew i was operating
because i'm on social media right there
are so many levels to this [ __ ] that are
is interesting right so number one they
my visibility is massive because like
the whole social media [ __ ] so they can
go they're showing up to my gym every
day so i'm gonna get to two things here
one thing there's a gym right down the
street and there's a gym right up the
street
how many counts do you think i had of
8.77b which was like you didn't listen
to what the [ __ ] we said order right
this is a real thing in california
did i have versus other two gyms the
same exact time operating the same exact
way
and actually bigger spaces how many
counts you think they had up the street
down the street and me what is it
there was one up the street and there
was eight down the street and there's 66
of mine wow so you're driving past these
gyms every day you're going that's you
know that and i'm like you guys so
anyways listen this is a celebrity [ __ ]
like they know you so they can clip you
and they can see my story every day yeah
right i'm not there doing what they say
i'm supposed to be doing yeah okay but
here's the deal with the lights this is
the craziest thing with the lights and
mind you i had some guys coming into my
gym who are like health officials i'm
not going to say this guy's name but he
was one of the health officials and he
comes in like dresses like a police
officer with a gun
and he's like you guys got to shut down
we're like what the [ __ ] and i have i
have a lot of like police officers who
go to my gym and they're like yo that
guy can't be in here
dressed like that he can't be in here
with a gun and like a
all this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] so anyways
the first time they shut my lights off
they hit the switch in the back we're
like yeah i'll bet yeah okay we'll turn
that and then we just turn it back on
right
the second time they shut the lights off
they go through the city and there's a
back door because my my you know the
landlord has the whole the whole year
they shut you off with them so listen
they shut us off at the lights in you
know the big building yeah and they put
a lock on our [ __ ] shut it up put a lock
right yeah
i was like oh [ __ ] okay so we operated
for three months just generated we put
like construction lights you know like a
construction light setup generate before
we put some speakers for the music so
night time it was like a [ __ ] club in
there but here's the thing
imagine three months ago but i'm like i
said i spent like six seven thousand
dollars a month just in gasoline to to
fuel these things right and i'm paying
my rent and all this other [ __ ] on top
of that so i was like yo i hit them up
and i said
email
and all this [ __ ] is tracked so if you
[ __ ] are listening this [ __ ]
i'll go we'll go straight back because i
want to take them to court for this [ __ ]
you should so imagine i'm saying hey i'm
following what you guys want me to
follow now certain orders they're like
you got to do this you got to do that if
you want to do this follow this i'm
saying hey can you come verify that
we're doing this
and imagine this they don't show up no
response to this day
to this day no response you came by 60
times before and now you can't come up
and pull it and i said can you turn my
lights back on i'm doing what you want
me to do no response to this day to this
day so how'd you get the lights back i
cut the [ __ ] lock and turned the
lights back on yeah yeah bro they're
doing illegal [ __ ] yeah that's illegal
like how would you not respond to that
is in what world is that not illegal
yeah like you can't be like oh we're
just oh we did that and we're just
dipping
you can't do that's [ __ ] illegal did
you ever think to just not post on
social media because it was bringing too
much attention oh [ __ ] that's stupid
was it gonna stop what i was doing i
mean you could stop posting something
immediately why would i do that i've
been doing that forever clubhouse you
know doing that forever all right fair
enough but yes during the time that's
your question it did there was a it was
like tons of people did you got it there
was massive lines people were like
waiting in the lobby because everyone to
[ __ ] work out like you're trying to
take something away from someone that is
like so basic people love and they feel
like they need this and it does so much
for their mental health yeah their
sanity and their bodies all this is like
people are gonna [ __ ] find that yeah
and even though they wanted to get
everyone don't do it or whatever it's
like people were finding that so yes
during that time it definitely it helped
during that time for sure yeah yeah